sentados apenas a 10 metros de distancia
el ministro de exteriores Ruso sergei
labrov y su homólogo estadounidense
Anthony blinken se ignoraron a
conciencia mientras las tensiones crecen
en todo el mundo los ministros de
exteriores se encontraron en el Foro de
las Naciones del sudeste asiático la
seán Indonesia el país anfitrión recordó
los invitados que su objetivo es
intentar resolver no escalar los
conflictos la
cian no es un escenario para la
competición no debe ser un representante
de ningún país y la ley internacional
debe ser respetada sistemáticamente
el lindo Pacífico no debe ser otro campo
de batalla
nuestra región debe permanecer estable y
tenemos la intención de mantenerlo así
[Música]
las tensiones van en aumento desde hace
años entre los países del sudeste
asiático y Beijing a raíz de los
reclamos de China de gran parte del mar
de la china meridional los incidentes
marítimos han crecido y los
desencuentros han llegado también a
Taiwán Estados Unidos comparte las
preocupaciones respecto a China
debemos defender la libertad de
navegación en los mares del sur y este
de la China y mantener la paz y la
estabilidad en el estrecho de Taiwán el
jueves las dos superpotencias
sostuvieron conversaciones sinceras
según palabras de blinken con el
objetivo de gestionar las diferencias
que los separan sin embargo el tema que
dominó la Cumbre fue mía al mar
sumergido en una violenta tormenta
política después del golpe de estado de
2021 el jueves el bloque reiteró la
necesidad de insistir en el plan de paz
de cinco puntos que ya se había acordado
con el gobierno militar de mi almar
hasta ahora la junta lo ha incumplido